now this net this next section is kind
of the
the central um ethos and thesis
of what you represent and i think that
um it's also represent you mean yeah
yeah
and me and me i mean this is a huge
pillar of what i'm passionate about and
have interviewed
hundreds of people about this exact
topic and so
this topic is basically the
idea that we are now able to take
a constant stream
of our biometrics and we
are able to tweak
where there is a
imbalance in a sense dr aubry de gray
uses the
analogy and you're gonna give us some as
well of the fact that like
why does a jet engine on an airplane
have hundreds of sensors
but why do we see the doctor one time a
year
right so these types of things and so
and so into the future and you're going
to hit this back right now is just that
the few this is the future is this
constant stream
and then the ability to correct
imbalances and then for us to
live healthier moment to moment
healthier stronger more creative and
also
longer and so that's this general idea
and we're going to get into a bunch of
the sub topics on this but yes go ahead
and um
and hit it hit it off no you you said
you know you had all the the adjectives
you can live healthier
moment etc i i just
aim for one i just want
to live equanimously yeah with
equanimity
right yes um which is
the highest form of love and the highest
form of love is peace and
yes highest form of peace is equanimity
so um
um you you actually already
hit on it when you know the jets have so
many sensors
and we used to think that the body
didn't have
uh as much of
molecules that can be sensed right and
uh when you go to an illness medicine
doctor essentially you already have a
flat tire
right your your heart has already given
out
right or you already have
an overheated engine you already have a
fever from an infection
right so as an illness medicine doctor
myself i'm a trained interventional
neuroradiologist right
um we know how to repair stuff
we we diago you bring your car to the
you know to the garage and we know how
to do retrospectively
oh this is actually it's not your
carburetor
you know it's this you know and so
our diagnostics are are um basically
retrospective
right so we know how to do repair right
and
we do repair uh our antibiotics have to
work on populations we're
dealing with populations all the time
right of of uh
of individuals because hey you know the
technique for
open heart surgery has to work
consistently throughout the world
right if you if you do it so but when
you go
and and and do that you're just looking
at repairing your system
right and then the concept of endless
medicine of
prevention is disease prevention so
the the the diabetic society will say
this is how you prevent
diabetes this is how and then the
neurology societies this is how you
prevent
alzheimer's and this is how you prevent
you know um
and so on so forth so if someone who has
hypertension and someone who has
cognitive decline and someone who has
cancer
and someone has diabetes you know they
will follow three
four different kinds of of prevention
guidelines and what the hell is that
you know um yeah so notice i used hell
all right i i usually use another
expletive
but are you really expecting patients to
do that
but it turns out that um you know it
you know our cars are so much better now
because every three thousand miles comes
a warning light that says okay
time for you to bring your car to the
garage and then
when the temperature is rising it shows
exactly
you know what the temperature is and
gives you a warning that you're about to
hit critical level
right or when your tire pressure is
going
down it's it's uh
gives you the level of your type
pressure and which tire right
yeah initially we didn't have those
kinds of diagnostics in medicine
right so all we were taught in illest
medicine
was pathology you know what's a disease
you know and how to repair it
pharmacology
by drugs or surgery cut him up or
do a combination of both right yeah so
so now but we also didn't have the
access in terms of the instrumentation
to see at
that level but now in the last really
like 100 years we got this instrument
because of the development
of science and technology right we are
now able to take a look inside the cell
in fact uh there's a reason why my
medical school classmates hate me right
because you're being dragged right back
into biochemistry inside the cell
whereas before you couldn't measure
those metabolites or small molecules
right
now you could measure them before you
will
you will just say oh just take vitamin c
and just
take vitamin e now i actually resent
that question
being asked of me it's like why don't
you [ __ ] measure it
and then take it if you need it right
because all of those can be measured now
yes it turns out that metabolomics which
is they're all mixed that's in there
clinical metabolomics which is the use
of it in the clinics it's
um it's already 40 years old right but
it's only hitting the clinics right now
wow right now but when you are dealing
with health
not disease you must have some objective
measure
of what it is that's going out of
balance you know it's a playbook
from uh illness medicine you diagnose
and treat disease right
so in health you detect and correct
imbalances
because there's no disease right and if
if there's a disease underlying that you
set the disease aside for the specialist
and you balance the uh imbalance of
hormones and nutrients and other
metabolites
that are in there right and
and if you place those values
between the values of uh when you were
21 and 30 years old
right yeah yeah yeah interesting then
you're at your
when you're at your peak homeostatic
capacity
yes yes yes okay except for
except for values like uh vitamin d for
example
vitamin d is actually a hormone i call
it the hormone named vitamin d
right but so then do we have a cat
those are evolutionarily determined
right so their evolutionary determined
values that came before us
right so there is this catalog in a
sense of
of optimized but then alan's
uh 21 year old uh catalog
of of of biometrics for an
optimized uh um equanimity and
equilibrium and homeostatic capacity
onward is different is somewhat similar
but also different than ted's so and yes
yes but it falls within a range right
it's usually higher
your needs for certain things is usually
higher right
and right now i've seen for example um
uh uh 21 22 year olds with growth
hormone levels of like
of that of a 70 year old you know you
could see how
how um uh how we've changed a lot
um versus south also geographically
right or in the
by the equator i mean or versus on
towards the poles
yeah and also um you know it's not only
that the
use of plastics for example they're
endocrine disruptor systems right they
disturb your hormonal levels like for
example they did a
i think it was like 60 000 men in europe
you know between ages 21 to 30 and they
found out already
drops in testosterone levels um
you know which used not to be there so
what we use
as a as a range is not what you use
for illness medicine right when when
when
clients or clients because they're not
sick right or patients come back
and say oh look my thyroid hormone is
normal
well that's just enough not to make you
sick
right yeah so it's like a in when you
say
in nutrition the rda or the recommended
dietary allowance
is just enough not for you to incur the
deficiency but it's not the optimal
value for you yes yes okay so let's
let's visualize this as well
you have a you have a really good visual
that i'll um
embed here but you have this you have
this
general idea of scale that
um we can envision here where you have
an idea of what's happening at this
quantum biophysics level and then you
have what's happening at the atomic
level at the molecular level the
macromolecular level organelle level
cell level tissue organ
organ systems and organisms so you have
that that
increase and then and then what you have
is you have
um it's it's really it's at this
intracellular
level is with the focus right now and at
this intracellular level
there are three categories pretty much
there's optimal sub-optimal
and illness and and and you
what we're talking about is basically
keeping your biometrics
at the optimal level so even when they
start
going into what are called like these
preliminary
phases of suboptimal levels
um that we can have those interventions
to return them
to optimal levels and these can be
measured via right
it's just like you know your windshield
wiper
um fluid is low top it off that may be
what you have low levels of alpha lipoic
acid you have low levels of vitamin b1
b2 or something and those are like the
newer
uh dashboards now that you have
now it's available to us unfortunately
it cannot you know those are the
fundamental functions of cells so we're
made of
organs and underneath the organs are the
specialized cells like
you know your your beta cells in your in
your pancreas for example that produce
insulin
but underneath all of these organs and
all of these specialized cells there's a
fundamental cell that has to run
it is a nucleus it has a mitochondria it
has a cytoplasm
you know it has a plasma reticula you
know um
you know it and it has cell membranes
and it has a cytoplasm
and no one's taking care of that and
that's fundamental
right yes so so a health optimization
is basically focused on health
maintenance
right it's maintaining like when you're
looking at your dashboard in your car
and saying oh this is slow
and that's low you know oh this is this
is uh overheating oh i need to change
oil now
now we actually have the technology to
do that which is through metabolomics
right
and i chose metabolomics for two reasons
one
the tests for them already mature
meaning we could
prove to illness medicine people like
hey look
you know remember those krebs cycle
intermediates that you just used to
memorize
here they are here are the levels and
usually they call me back and they go
achacosa what do i do with this i said
ah
so anyway because it's used for health
right it's
it's fundamental so when you are doing
health optimization
you don't do one organ at a time right
you do the fundamental cell
in all of your body yes you gave this
really good example is basically if you
go
and you um target the specific like
pancreatic cell
that is starting to have a little bit
closer towards sub-optimal
what you do is if you and i and i want
to see if you make the correction
it basically does all of the downstream
much better yeah now
now will you teach me yeah make no
claims because illness medicine
will will you know shoot me for that and
that's the reason why functional
medicine
you know has a lot of fights with other
illness medicine doctors right
but for me it's enough to move
uh the the values of your vitamins your
your macronutrient uh uh components like
your essential amino acids and so on
and your your micronutrients your
vitamins
minerals you know and cofactors and your
hormones
if you move them to to the optimal
levels
then you see the effects without any
claims right
yes yes the system tends to correct
itself
yes it's like it's like in very simple
terms it's like
huh i've been sitting for a long time my
back hurts and then you go and you swim
and then you come and then right when
you're out of the pool you're like oh my
gosh i feel so much better
so that's the intervention towards
optimal at the organism
higher level now ted i wanna i wanna ask
you this
at um let's talk about this how do we
take
a sample from my body
to gain the the intracellular
metabolomic
knowledge of what sugars what lipids
what nucleotides
um etc are uh our our
amino acids are are there and what
um and then where they're out of range
the ideas
then some are out of range and then how
do you give an
intervention like how do you analyze
that is that through mass
uh spec spectrometry and then
um from there then how do you um provide
the intervention so
walk us through that whole cycle um so
um what you do they do is uh they take
uh
urine blood uh for me i take stool
samples because i have to take check
your
gut microbiota right they're a separate
organ they're not considered a postnatal
organ in the body um which influence
which is a major influence on your
immune system
right yes and
so it's a blood urine and so uh we
send them out to a metabolomic slab
um so so essentially
they have all of this um uh
uh you know the gold standard right now
is what they call the lcm sms or the
liquid chromatography
um mass spectrometromatory but
it's already found like they're
quadrupoles and blah blah blah
the newer uh you know and right now it's
a race
to provide uh to to to
get to the protocols with the least
invasive sampling like for example
you now know the sensor on the toilet
um contact lenses
right now you have the continuous
monitoring uh
over here but that's individual right uh
that's uh for for individual use if
if you're like weird like us who like to
you know i puncture myself three times a
week for my blood ketone
levels and from blood sugar even if i'm
not diabetic right
yeah um yeah so so um
so after that so the results come in
and what's nice is that they've already
done enough statistical analysis
to give you you know uh
what is the suggested um
amount that should be given to the
client it's already there
however you need to adjust right you
need to adjust things
um like for example
um uh for example
if you see like for example the the uh
the zinc level is very very high right
for
the patient so you you refer the client
right
and inter season and you ask you know
have you been taking lots of
of um zinc lozenges and yeah it's
artificial elevator then you'll see the
copper dropping
right so you could see that uh the
system knows
you know there are counter balances to
things if you take too much saying the
copper will drop
you know that's just the way you know
you you will get
balanced by through evolution right um
and so so after that then
the way so you you come to me the the
reason why it's nice is because this
lens itself
it lends itself to telemedicine right or
tele health practice
yeah because you never have to see your
client or you never have to see your
patient
because you cannot say hello how are you
molecule
you know i you know how are you feeling
today you can't do that you have to look
at the values
you know of the molecules themselves
what are the levels like yeah
like you're gonna say hello b12 you know
um what's your status today you can't uh
but for for most clients uh so
essentially you
you take a look and you essentially do a
protocol
for them right which which ones are to
be taken um
before meals as soon as they will wake
up before they
before they take a meal while they're
eating especially those who
who have taken too many proton pump
inhibitors like nexium
and so on you know where you're giving
them like a beta in
hydrochloride acid to acidify their
stomachs you know
and also so there's a protocol that goes
on and then
things that you take after a meal right
and then things that you take before
bedtime
so because you know hormones follow they
earn a level you know there's a certain
pattern to all of these things of course
if you take alpha lipoic acid before
meals your blood sugar will go down
right and you will feel busy because
it's a hypoglycemic agent
uh so you you should you know that's why
i
i started this whole health of musician
medicine and practice
in order to be able to to teach this the
clinical practice is very simple
you measure the metabolites right and
you know that they are in a network if
you touch one metabolite
or you touch one hormone the other
hormone will
will uh respond that's why i don't let
oh you should replace your testosterone
without replacing all the other things
that you need to replace right
it's it's a bad practice because they're
all in a network and as you know my life
is about networks
so yeah um and so
you move the you give them i usually
give them
supplements for the first 90 days
because even if they say well dr ted i'm
gonna
uh you know i'm gonna eat properly i
promise and blah blah and
you ask some okay what foods are high in
in coenzyme cutane and they don't know
okay what foods are high in uh alfalfa
acid they don't know right so uh for the
first 90 days just to catch up with the
deficiencies i
i tell them look you didn't get
to these deficiencies overnight this
occurred over time
with your habits with your lifestyle and
with everything else this is what it's
showing
let's catch up as fast as possible so
you know uh the improvement can come
anywhere within two weeks like if you're
doing hormone therapy or
you know uh three to nine months if
you're doing nutrient
nutrient therapy and you you you're a
measure
whether or not you're actually
addressing all these things like
yeah yeah um yeah because you you gain
because you're you're taking again
because there's so many sensors right on
this
jet now that we're getting the frequent
readouts of improvements